and his verification is for 100 million
dollars liquid plus
and so the guy has over 100 million
dollars
and he did it all through
two or three of these apps and i believe
with close to no employees and he did it
over around like eight or ten years
[Music]
what up what up
they told us to do
uh intros now of the podcast so this is
my first million
podcast where uh
we tell you 100 good ideas half are good
half are bad but it's on you to figure
out which ones this is my first million
where i make fun of sam about how he
talks he makes fun of me about how i
look and in between we squeeze in a few
business ideas let's see what else what
else we got for them and supposedly uh
we're supposed to be successful people
so it's like the reviews people say they
say it's kind of like we're just sitting
at a bar with a bunch of our
successful friends dare i say i hate
this word right multi-millionaire
friends and just hear what they talk
about that
just a couple of deck of millionaires
hanging out
dude
yeah how are you supposed to brag about
that you know what i learned from from
my last successful venture i now take
those learnings to the podcast
can i just say that regardless of the
deca millionaire nonsense i did
something
a few weeks ago that i think was amazing
i bought a 60 tattoo gun on amazon and i
let my wife give me a hand tattoo
instead of wearing a wedding ring
oh wow totally worth it
uh let let me be the judge can you bring
that a little closer here
what is it it's just an x
can you see it is it
right like it uh that's not focusing
okay it's an x like you know it's an
infected x but it's an x you know like
where where something was there then
it's like dead and now you've like put
an x there that's kind of the vibe
you're going for or what yeah or like
you know triple x on like a moonshine
whiskey jug
yeah something like that
and she wanted to do this or you want to
do this she seems more sensible than you
so i don't know of course she didn't
want to do it i just said sarah i bought
this tattoo i'd sit down right now or
otherwise i'm just going to do it myself
uh okay threats and i handed her an
orange rage and threats
yeah like literally i set it up and
within two minutes it was done i handed
her an orange i go right next on that
orange great i'll do that on my fist
people always ask us what's the secret
to being a decca millionaire and we tell
them
it's threats
you've got to threaten your your
business partners your marital partners
you've got to threaten all your partners
actually same you you you kind of do use
this sort of like i wouldn't call it
threat but as they say it's always sunny
um it's the implication of danger you i
feel like you you do use this the
implication of things going wrong am i
am i right about that
what's an example
in your management style like you know
you're trying to get the team motivated
you have two paths you could go down you
could you could start with why and tell
them why you're so excited about this
why this is good for them
or
you could just hit him with a with a
solid threat with the implication of
things not going so well if we don't do
x which way do you go
i like the second one i'm more of a guy
who will do like
if if i can all right tell me how you
are if you can make a million dollars or
not lose a million dollars which one are
you more motivated to do
for me not lose a million dollars and
i'm saying for you the same same
absolutely save it's not to do something
so i love setting my life up and i do
this all the time with like my wife and
stuff i'd be like oh [__] like i already
booked it like we already we got to do
this thing or uh you know i always set
stuff up that if i don't do it there's
consequences that's the way to live man
and i used to do it with my employees
all the time and you know what they
always said they hated it and then
whenever they leave and quit uh
eventually uh they'll say something like
yeah but i did so much cool [__] and we
actually got a lot of stuff done so i
think people actually like it
right yeah they tell their therapist as
they just spend years recovering from
you
yeah i guess so dude can we do you have
a bunch of topics
i got a few yeah i got a couple too can
i start on one that like i think it's
blowing my mind and i so yeah basically
yesterday i went on a long walk i did i
went on like a 10 mile walk you ever go
on a long walk
i go on a walk i got a dog yeah yeah i
just went on a really long walk and i
went and walked around all these fancy
neighborhoods in brooklyn and i started
you know i do what what people do i pull
up zillow as i'm walking and i'm like
you know i wonder what it's like to live
here
and the houses that i like what i
usually will do is i see a house and i
go oh i would like to live there and i
pull it up and it's eight million
dollars
and eight million dollars that's one
number but then you actually look at how
much money you need to come up on at
closing and then you look at how much
money you need to uh spend each and
every month on the mortgage and on your
interest and on maintenance and things
like that
and i started thinking
i think i'm going to live over here in
brooklyn and i wanted to like map out
how much money i would expect i would
spend to live the lifestyle i want to
spend and it is astronomical and i
wanted to talk about some some of those
expenses
you want to talk about something
walk me through it okay so listen to
this first of all i'm going to talk
about the life that i'm going to live
when i move to brooklyn and all the
listeners there's gonna be a bunch of
them that's gonna say oh sam no one
needs an eight million dollar house yeah
i get it you know like all i need is
like a bucket of water and like some
apples and like a pair of crocs and i'm
happy but this is the life that i choose
to live so like i get it no one needs
this but i'm picking this so get off my
back on this hypothetical case that
might be a reality in two years so i
just got to get that out of the way but
in terms of hypotheticals it's not
entirely hypothetical because i went and
talked to a couple friends who do this
but listen to this [__]
so
i found a home that i wanted to buy and
i actually linked to it on the the mbd
master dock okay so it's a street it's
on street easy it's a nice house okay
it's only 3 000 square feet though but
it's a brown stone in my favorite
neighborhood of cobble hill it's five
million dollars i actually think the
range of things i want are between five
and eight but this one i just found it
was available it's five million dollars
which basically means i gotta come up
with 1.1 million dollars as my down
payment and then i'm gonna spend around
twenty thousand dollars a month in
mortgage and interest and and things
like that not including maintenance
which is gonna be uh more expensive it's
gonna be probably another two or three
thousand dollars a month
then
i think it would probably cost on the
low end 50 000 on the middle only end of
like a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to furnish it the way i'd like
to furnish it right have you ever
furnished a house
yeah yeah it depends if you go like like
my wife she's like oh yeah i'm like what
do you like she's like restoration
hardware i'm like ah geez like you know
every item in the store is like 400 000
to 10 000
and so you know you just add that up per
room you're putting in like 20 to 25
grand worth of stuff per per room uh in
the house which is pretty nuts yeah
totally so like 150k is that's just kind
of what it would cost if you want to go
that route if you want to go west m west
elm then yeah you can maybe get it done
for 175 000 but it's quite expensive
then
if i'm going to get this fat house i'm
getting it because i have two kids or a
couple kids so i need my 40 000 50 000 a
year nanny i imagine i would spend
around 30 000 a year in food and so
basically it comes up to where i think
i'm spending
600 to 700 000
a year to live the life i want to live
in brooklyn but
here's the kicker if you're making over
a million dollars a year in brooklyn or
or for sure in manhattan it's even more
than this
half your money goes away to taxes
so basically if i'm spending around six
hundred thousand dollars a year i need
to make 1.2 million dollars
just to cover my my monthly number break
even just a break even
and if i if it's and i i talked to two
friends one friend who lives in brooklyn
he told me that he spends around 500 000
a year and then another friend that also
lives nearby and he told me he spends
eight hundred thousand dollars a year
and he spent me he sent me his uh list
but he goes i have an uh an additional
house in north uh rhode island but if
you take that uh vacation home we are
spending around 650 000 a year
so to to live like this it's crazy and
when you go and walk on these streets
you know there's a house every block if
you go in manhattan there's this fancy
apartment every block how on earth do
you think people so many people afford
this
it's crazy like when you actually think
about the logistics right well
well a lot of the people who owned these
homes they owned them
before they were worth 5 million so go
look at the you know the zillow history
of this thing 10 years ago what was this
home worth you know i'm guessing it's
less than
you know less than half this maybe 35
percent of this price 10 years ago 30
percent
and so you're what you're talking about
here is like you know a home that that
they bought in their basis is a million
million and a half dollars something
like that instead of five so now the
monthly payment is less and now the
property taxes are less and so you know
you cut out your biggest expense in this
case um you you trim that down so i
think that's that's the answer for how a
lot of people have this is inheritance
or um or buying in you know 20 years ago
15 years ago
when these were worth a fraction of what
they're worth today and so that's why
they can afford to kind of live above
their weight well so i had four
takeaways when i started thinking about
this the first was that there's a story
behind everything so all these people
like a simpleton like me is like oh you
just got to earn this much money and
they did it by starting a business it's
like no that's not the reality and zach
crockett who works at the hustle he
basically we were talking about this and
he was going to write a story on this
and he said that he researched a bunch
of these homes and what he did was he uh
uh for all the five million dollar bro
over a bunch of five million dollar
brown so it's an nyc he used a tool
called melissa and he looked up the
property records then he googled the
names uh of each person who quote owned
it and then he like looked at their
family records which she just did this
all through just sleuthing and like look
at their stuff and he found out that a
bunch of them like seven out of ten of
them were like teachers or artists or
or or a professor things that you
basically like you can earn a bunch of
money but you're not earning enough
money to buy this home and what he
surmised and came to the conclusion was
like they just get a lot of help and so
like it's hard to own a five million
dollar brownstone when you're a reporter
at the new york post or some like you
know
120 000 your job so i think there's a
story behind everything the second thing
is i think you just have to earn a lot
of money dude listen to this if you earn
uh one hang on
hang on
that was a
killer insight what
the you gotta earn a lot of money
yeah where did you come up with that you
got to earn a lot of money but listen
let's let's put the math on this how
many how many years do you think you
need to uh how long would it take you to
save 10 million if you lived in new york
to save 10 million
yeah
to get a portfolio of 10 million uh
i have no idea i don't know let's say 20
years
okay so if you make 1.5 million dollars
and you're spending around 25 000 a
month in living expenses it's to take
you around 15 years to be able to save
10 million
which is pretty crazy now you've got to
figure out how to earn at least a
million and a half for 10 years
or for 13 years which is like
that in itself is impossible or not
impossible very very very challenging
and so
hold on you refer your first thing was
like these people are teachers and
artists and you said they got to have
some help you're talking about like
family help you're not talking about
like there's nothing else right you're
saying you have rich family
yeah
okay all right sorry i carry on i think
that i think just having a like i
underestimated that when i think about
this i'm like whose parents would give
them two million dollars for a down
payment on a home and i think the answer
to that is actually a lot
i can i i can't imagine that but the
answer like that that was hard for me
because you know i don't [__] know
that my mom and dad like the best gift
they ever gave me was when i turned 21
they gave me a thousand dollars and that
was like the last birthday present i
ever got i i don't even think it's a
down payment because okay you're a
teacher great your down payment is
covered where are you coming up with 25k
a month of your monthly monthly payment
just for your home like i think it
allows you i think
this is a this is an all cash
here's your house free and clear you get
to live here and you cover your life
expenses if you're paying for a latte
that's you but uh i'll buy you this
brownstone i think that's got to be what
it is
i think that's that that has to be what
it is or the second thing is you gotta
earn a lot the third thing is i think
you gotta i want how many of them do you
think sell a business i think earning a
lot like a big nut of 10 20 million
dollars
it seems like impossible to do without
selling an asset
you got to be in finance law
um maybe medicine or consulting to be
pulling in a million dollars a year of
income i i don't think there are many
other jobs
that do that we're not talking about
athletes entertainers because that's
just a small such a small portion of the
population but of jobs that a normal
person can get that's gonna make you a
million to two million dollars a year
i'm pretty sure you've got to be either
a banker or a banker or consultant if
you're employed or you got to be
self-employed as a doctor or a lawyer or
something like that to be able to pull
that in so that's like am i missing one
that's like those are just better those
are yeah those are non-entrepreneurial
jobs like the other ways and then you
can start your own business yeah
yeah yeah exactly you own a small
business you own a big business you um
you know you own a contracting firm you
do construction around the city whatever
it is those are the other way where you
can do this and that's usually
you're not earning some steady 1.5
million per year you're earning like
nothing nothing nothing a lot a lot lot
huge and then back to nothing you know
like that sort of thing it's this it's
this lumpy curve that an entrepreneur
has where you're basically broke till
you're very unbroke um so yeah
but
uh yeah what else you got to say about
this and my third and final takeaway
here is basically
there's so much out there there's so
much money out there there is so much
opportunity you walk by all these places
and again ben's laughing at me this is
obvious but it when you see it in real
life i walk down the street and i'm like
oh that apartment that costs 12 000 a
month to rent in that top floor of that
brown store stone and there's three of
those in there so like there's three
people each paying 12 000 and they're
just like home home home home home home
home it's astronomical there's just so
much money out there to be made it's
just so much opportunity so anyway i did
this three hour walk yesterday and i
just
i felt enlightened and i just wanted to
come to the table and fill you in on
that nothing nothing nothing um
spectacular
well that's why uh i'm glad you started
the show with something unspectacular uh
that's why you know these tick tocks
that are like they stop somebody in a
fancy car or a fancy house and they go
hey i just want to know what do you do
for a living
and the guy's like um and they're like
you know first of all like is this like
a trap are you like an irs agent what is
this and they're like
uh i paint houses or they'll be like you
know i um i work in real estate uh uh
you know i work in the financial
services industry and it's like oh okay
what's going on here but i think the
reason those are popular
is because wealth for most people is a
complete mystery it is a complete black
box unless you come from wealth if you
come from wealth and you grow up and at
your you know you're going to 15th
birthday parties where like serena
williams is there to play tennis with
the other kids you're like what the hell
like you know like this is everything is
just nice everybody goes uh we summer in
the hamptons you have a place where you
summer like summering is a verb uh and
then you you know you you know that
you're oh my god father you know he's he
owns like 44 dental practices and so you
if you grow up with wealth you wealth
doesn't seem like this mysterious
unattainable thing you in fact you
realize there's like a thousand paths
and it's up to you to decide which one
you want but for most people
wealth is like kind of just this
mysterious thing you don't even see how
wealthy people live you don't hear like
the numbers you talked about i think for
a lot of people listening they're gonna
be like what in the hell is sam talking
about somebody pays five hundred
thousand eight hundred thousand dollars
a year of just their living expenses
like that sounds like the most money you
could make let alone spend per year and
so when you're talking about spending
more than a person's life savings in a
year that's i think very foreign to
people then you say okay well how do you
achieve that and now you have maybe one
example two examples you don't have like
25 35 45 examples to choose from and so
i think that's why those tick tock
channels are popular i think that's why
this podcast is popular because
you either react to this type of
information with one of two reactions
bitterness or inspiration
for most people it's bitterness you hear
about other people's success or their
extravagant spending and you get bitter
you see the difference between what they
do and what you do and you don't focus
on the fact that maybe you want to do it
instead you focus on the fact that
they're wrong evil unnecessary blah blah
whatever it is and how you know they
only could have got it by by sort of
cheating the system or some unfair
advantages and you get bitter and that's
where i would say 90 of people fall into
the bitter camp but some people they
hear those stories and they take
inspiration and if you take inspiration
you start to collect each of these
anecdotes you start to collect each of
these data points and you say oh i'm
taking this foggy map that i have this
cloudy map where i couldn't really see
and i'm just pushing away the fog i'm
getting clarity on wow there's a
thousand ways to win and wow winning it
can be a lot bigger than i even imagined
and once you sort of have that in your
head
that's when things become a lot easier
because you start to notice all around
you examples of people building wealth
in unique ways and ways that are not
always long and hard ways that are not
always painful or required genius you'll
start to see examples of somebody who
does it by you know simply like you know
starting a mushroom farm in california
and it's like yeah that's what they do
or somebody i remember i met a guy who
created the tread that goes on
treadmills he's like yeah we're tread
manufacturer i said what and he's like
and these guys would do like 15 million
a year in sales and was he a marketing
genius no was he a sales genius no he
just simply was like oh there's demand
for tread that goes on conveyor belts
treadmills how much you probably say you
think
i mean i don't know i was like i was
like in fifth grade at the time i
remember it was my friend's dad and i
was like why why is why is jordan so
rich and i was like oh jordan's rich
because jordan's dad sells treads on
treadmill and then we met these other
people who are rich and they i was like
you know again i wasn't even asking the
question but i remember my sister saying
something like yeah they have like
mushroom farms
and i've ever been like in my head
farmers don't make like tons of money
and then i realized pretty quickly oh
farmers can make a ton of money and so
you know but i was just slowly
collecting these antidotes only when i
was in my 20s and i was like
if i want to know how to get rich then i
need to know like
a lot more examples of richness and if i
want to get rich fast and i need to get
examples of people getting rich fast
and
this is actually a good transition we
have a friend
who is
we were just in the group chat uh we
have a friend who it seems like might
get rich very quickly here
let me explain richer
they
created a product or a service or an app
and
they every day they're posting a chart
of like the growth of this thing and
it's like an early version of a hockey
stick it's like yep we went from doing
100 a day 500 a day thousand dollars a
day today three thousand dollars a day
today is gonna be nine thousand dollars
a day pretty quickly like you know fast
forward two weeks this person's gonna
put a chart in there that's gonna show
them doing 200 000 in revenue just today
and it's going to be nothing has changed
it's just they just let the growth carry
on and you see that you're like wow
that's that's winning like that's the
hov lane that's the fast lane where you
could just go in and you could win
faster like jeez i didn't realize that i
thought i gotta
bust my ass for 10 years and the reality
is this person has been busting their
ass for 10 years building up the skills
so that they can launch a new product
and they can do let's call it five to
ten million this year
in in potential profits now
this person if you remember
uh many months ago and they told us they
told us this exact this exact thing they
go
yeah i'm just thinking about ideas that
can make
i forgot what they said 10 or 50 million
dollars
i want to make 10 million dollars in a
year 50 million dollars in a year
and i was like okay like you know
yeah sure you know and i want jessica
alba to you know add me on snapchat
right now like but it's not necessarily
going to happen like you could just say
it but he was like no i've been studying
there's apps that do that in the app
store
and he's like showing us 12 examples
yeah
yeah just showing your screenshots and
examples it's like that does that yeah
this does that yeah and you now you see
10 of them and all of a sudden
first of all i never knew somebody who
even stated a goal like that so just
hearing it for the first time was like
that's interesting i knew people that
would say
i want to build a huge company a billion
dollar company that was normal i'd heard
that before i'd heard i want to get a
high paying job you know i want to make
500k a year at this company i've heard
that before i never really heard
somebody be like i'm looking for a way
that i can make 10 million dollars in
three months that was actually the exact
thing how do i make 10 million dollars
in three months
and so i was like all right well
never heard that that was new then i
thought well my brain doesn't come up
with any examples of how to do that
that's like you know doesn't involve you
know putting a ski mask on and walking
into a wells fargo so like
you know
and then he gave me 10 examples and so i
was like okay well now i got 10 examples
number 11 doesn't seem so far-fetched at
that point and i remember coming to
talking to you and being like
dude
have you heard anybody think like this
talk like this come up with ideas like
this because i believe that there's
great power in questions and i never
really heard somebody ask the question
how do i make 10 million dollars in the
next three months and once that question
was asked now my brain has to start
coming up with the answers and at first
my brain was struggling
and then as he gave me examples it
started to get better and better and
better come up with examples about how
you might do that and now it's literally
happening like that right in front of us
scenario is actually playing out right
in front of us what do you think of this
i think it's awesome i think i think
it's still too early i think anything
that comes fast will go away fast or can
go away fast but he called his shot and
we are seeing on a daily basis whether
it's come
it's coming it is in fact now coming
into reality and i think it's awesome i
think that there's ways i think peter
thiel said it where he's like what's
your five year goal and then someone
says their goal and he says cool how can
you do that six months
so i usually believe in that this guy
took it even further which is what's
your five year goal do it in three
months
and it's awesome and there's another guy
who i know that's done this and he's
public his name is alan wong do you have
the uh the the
app on your iphone that lets you listen
to police scanners it's like the police
scanner app
no but i know i know of these apps these
are it's like they're weird yeah it's
like
5-0 radio app i think like 5-0 radio app
and this this guy alan wong he posted in
reddit in 2013 and he basically said um
uh
he said hey i'm alan wong i was told to
create naming right here have it up here
yeah you wanna you wanna read it or you
read i have it up here he goes yeah he
goes
i'm a pr
ask me anything i'm a person in his 20s
who went from rags to vicious during the
recession he goes how i did it i develop
apps my most popular app is called the
5-0 radio police scanner it lets you
listen to police chatter around the
world you've probably seen this used in
the latest spider-man movie although
they rebranded it
and as of 2012 my apps have been
downloaded by 20 million people by the
way this is 10 years ago he wrote this
so he did this in the 2008. well i have
an update on it that i can give you in a
second so so he goes my parents were
raised in the slums of china they fled
here with my brother to new york my
mother worked in a sweatshop in
chinatown before she quit became a
homemaker my father was a herbalist
before he passed away unnaturally three
months after i graduated from college
after his passing no one in my family
had a job
and so he says i found a full-time job
at columbia university i was the only
one with income so i taught myself how
to create apps in my free time and i
created apps on the weekends with hopes
of making some side income i didn't
expect this to make me millions
and then he says where did he say his
money i don't think he says his money
somewhere here but uh yeah go ahead fill
in the gaps so he doesn't say it there
but i found it so there's this other
subreddit that i talk about all the time
called fat fire and they've got this
particular type of flare called verified
by the mods where the mods the
moderators
look at the income or your balance sheet
they look at something and they say yeah
we believe it what you are saying is
true and his verification is for 100
million dollars liquid plus
and so the guy has over 100 million
dollars
and he did it all through
two or three of these apps and i believe
with close to no employees and he did it
over around like eight or ten years
it said he by the way he says
so he has three apps he has 5.0 radio
then he has police scanner plus
and then he has one more called what is
it called
um
hang on he's got three apps
that were in the top
like the top hundred so so he goes this
means i'm the only person ever in app
store history this is what he wrote at
the time this was back in i don't know
2012 2013 something like that
i'm the only person in history to have
in
the app
to have three apps in the app store that
were top 10 overall in the paid and free
categories at the same time yeah man
this guy's cool and then he if you
google his username it's rego apps so
r-e-g-o apps and then fat fire you'll
see his posts from fat fire and he talks
about uh what it's like to be uh
different tiers of rich and he has all
types of of like you know when i was at
this thing this is how i felt when i was
at this other thing this is how i felt
and now according to his flair it's over
a hundred million it's a this is so
you're asking who else do i know that's
done this i don't know this guy and i
can't verify that any of this is true
but it's pretty interesting and it might
be true well yeah and i don't know the
speed that this guy did it but um still
amazing by the way we should get
verified in fat fire why aren't we
posting in fat fire that seems like a
that's our those are our people we
should hang out i do post there i post
there under a name that no one knows me
as but i would post there more would you
po do do uh you use this
yeah i'll go browse i never post never
comment but i'll i'll make an account
and i'll uh let's do it let's get
verified let's do an ama there yeah so
look this guy's thing says i fat f i
found his username he was i fat fired at
age 25 i make 10 million dollars a year
in my 30s 10 yeah 10 million plus a year
in my 30s and i have over 100 million
dollars according to which has been
verified for the mods and here this is
what he says someone says what's the
difference in millionaires or in money
levels he goes at 100k to a million you
can tip very generously and be okay with
that at one to five million you could
fund some medical expenses and maybe a
college college tuition or two maybe for
an extended family member or friend at
five to twenty you could pay off a
handful of college tuition i guess
they're asking about donation you can
pay off a handful of college tuitions
and some expensive surgeries and then he
jumps to
uh 50 to 50 million you can create
several non-profits and overseas that uh
that are overseas and help people uh at
a community level like building a school
or a local community or something so he
like talks about this constantly
throughout this subreddit and it's very
very interesting yeah that's cool i like
that uh that's a good story i um
i uh i'm gonna have another story to
share on this and let's call it
30 days let's say i'm going to call i'm
going to leave that little seed here 30
days i'll have another interesting story
to share on this topic but let's switch
to something else
[Applause]
[Music]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool
a billion dollars
[Music]
let's talk about um
this guy scott painter do you know who
scott painter is this is my
this is my billy of the week this is guy
scott painter i don't know if he's a
billy but he's got that big billy energy
for sure and i'm going to tell you this
guy's story and you're going to be
you're going to be amazed by this guy
all right go for it
do you know who i'm talking about do you
know who have you ever heard this name
before no i'm just looking it up now
so scott painter isn't known because he
was the ceo of something called truecar
and so truecar is like a super
successful um
it was like one of the super successful
early uh
car companies on the internet so what
they were doing was they were publishing
price information so that you could go
and figure out you know the what the
true price of this car is so that um you
know if before you would go to a
dealership and depending on which dealer
you went to and which sales person you
talked to and how they sort of
sized you up as a sucker you would get
like a 30 price differential on the
price of the same car
so you could go to one place and the
same exact car they'll they'll charge
you um you know
30 more or less depending on uh which
place you went so it's a huge spread
after truecar people could just go
figure out well this is the price of
this car a 1997 you know mazda miata is
suppose with this many miles is supposed
to be this price and in every market
they would go into the price gaps that
that dealers were charging would spread
would change from thirty percent down to
like three percent and so they were like
helping bringing prices transparency but
this dude is a crazy story he is built
he has basically spent like 20 years
just constantly trying to reinvent the
auto industry online so this guy did uh
i'm just going to read you like his his
linkedin so he's um he's the he starts
off well he goes to the army first of
all and he's a spanish interrogator
which is just like kind of a crazy
little path that he took
and he talks about like you know why he
went there it's like you know
my you know dad wasn't so cool i needed
freedom army was freedom for me so i
went to the army and um
so anyways he he goes and he becomes vp
of marketing at 1 800 car search this is
early internet we're talking like 1999
basically and so there's 1 800 car
search 1 800 dentist he's like the vp
marketing for each then he creates like
a consult so he's just hopping one year
one year after that he creates dental
advantage it's like consulting for
dennis about how to use the internet
then he starts another one called vision
incorporated it's again 1999-ish and
he's like helping companies transform
like for e-commerce like hey companies
are gonna need to do e-commerce i'm
gonna help them do this so he he was
right he was just way early on on this
trend of e-commerce and then he just
starts this like crazy run in the car
industry so he goes
he's the founder of cars direct they go
from zero to 650 million in sales in
year one
then he goes he's starting starts
advertising.com
yeah then he's ceo and founder of
truecar then he ceo and founder of
pricelock which was like uh lock andy or
like gas prices
then he was a founder then after so he
does truecar he takes it public
and he gets on this crazy scenario where
he is the uh i think he's the largest
individual shareholder
he's not only the largest of his
shareholder he's buying up a ton of
stock he believes in the stock like
crazy
they have an earnings miss uh like the
economy sort of turns car owner people
start slow down with their car buying
they have a big quarter miss stock drops
like crazy
he gets margin called because he was
buying so much of his own stock
and he's basically forced to borrow
money from friends to pay off his margin
call
and he he resigns from the company that
same month he basically has to step down
as ceo he lost a ton of money on his own
stock
he gets a divorce and his literal house
burns down
[Laughter]
what does he do the following week
the following week he incorporates
fair.com
to a new way to buy cars and this was
like basically the idea that like hey
car buying is super super complicated
you go you buy a car i don't know if
you've ever done it but like the process
of you have to buy a car you have to
qualify for financing like you know 80
of cars are financed in the united
states no nobody buys cars all cash here
and um
and then you have like this complicated
like credit check payment thing then you
have your your insurance on top you have
your title insurance you have to do the
right registration you have to do all
this different stuff and he's like what
if instead it was like you know what if
buying a car was as simple as like
buying a coffee or netflix like
subscription so what he would do is you
would just put in your phone number it
would like find out all your information
it would and it would say what card you
want you pick a car it'll be like cool
that car's 500 a month
and you own that car and you could turn
it in at any time if you don't want that
car so it's like a long-term rentals
basically was what fair was doing
fair grows like crazy they raised
hundreds of millions of dollars because
hey this guy is got this crazy track
record b he's very like kind of
charismatic and uh formidable like you
see this guy as a founder you're like
god i would hate to be competing against
this guy in the same market and he
thinks very big he's like you know we're
gonna change the way that car ownership
is done we're gonna make this faster
cheaper whatever softbank piles in 300
million dollars into a series b round
and um and they're on their way
and fare ends up going up really fast
and then crashing really fast because
uh a few years ago i don't know if you
know basically like the as the tech
markets like valuations turned softbank
was which was the big whale and the
space started losing money they lost
money on we work then they lost money on
uh was the other big one softbank had
like i don't know three or four like
huge things like uber like they had a
bunch of huge things going like
the prices crashed from where they had
invested
and so
he couldn't raise any more money and he
had built this like very complicated
thing they were laying out 40 people
fair doesn't really work out
and now he's back again because i see
this thing that says
this new startup autonomy has placed 400
million dollars worth of purchase orders
to buy 8 000 something teslas this year
i was like what who's buying 8 000
teslas who's paying 400 million dollars
to buy teslas and it's a startup called
autonomy that is trying to make it where
you can just rent electric cars
simply like you you there's a lot of
people that want to own a electric car
like a tesla and um they can't afford it
it's too expensive all in so here pay
this monthly fee and you get to rent a
tesla you get to own you basically you
get to like have a test so you're not
renting it
it's a long term rental
he's back and so they've placed one
billion dollars of purchase orders
across different electric vehicle
manufacturers to do this so he's he's
back he must have raised a ton of money
again plus like raised a bunch of debt
and uh he's back with his new startup
drive autonomy and this guy is
fascinating i went down a rabbit hole
listening to interviews with this guy
how do you come on your radar
interesting dude
because of this autonomy thing i worked
backwards from the last thing i told you
where i was like but why were you just
looking up purchase orders of electric
cars
i saw two i saw tweet you know you i
follow on twitter like you know elon and
a bunch of like these like kind of tesla
fanboy and tesla hater accounts like
that i follow both sides like there's
basically a huge group of people that
are i should actually say it's a small
group of people that believe tesla is a
giant fraud and is going to zero they're
called tesla q and then there's other
people that believe that elon musk is
you know the second coming of jesus and
i follow both and in the second coming
of jesus camp they were like tesla you
know the huge you know here's more good
news for tesla these guys drive autonomy
has placed 400 million dollars of of
orders for for teslas because there's so
much demand and elon had replied saying
um
he was like demand has never been the
problem it's supply like manufacturing
like production of cars is our problem
like yeah this is good news but like we
don't have a demand problem we have so
much demand we have supply problem but i
was curious
where is this you know half a billion
dollars of demand coming from i've never
heard of this startup before what do
they do
and um and that's what they what was he
like when you hear him talk is he
charismatic he just looks like an uh a
normal very charismatic
very matter of fact um
so he's basically like he's a good
storyteller he's quick and to the point
he um he reminds me a lot of like you
know that other guy we like frank
slootman the guy who runs snowflake who
wrote that amazing blog post amp it up
which basically describes like
you know don't be such a wuss like you
know
run your company to win and we're here
to win and like this is the plan to win
and uh that guy's just been like a
serial ceo of companies that just grow
really fast
this guy's like that um so let me tell
you some of the kind of like interesting
little nuggets that came out of this so
i'm just going to keep rambling on this
guy so he's basically he's like uh he's
like i'm a multi-time college dropout
like i have dropped out of college
multiple times i dropped out of like my
kind of prep college i dropped out of
undergrad um i dropped out of grad
school
and he's like i basically had a ton of
failure do you guys know me because i've
tried like 25 things and three have
worked
and he's like you know but that's
entrepreneurship like you know you need
three to work out of 25 in a 20-year
career and like that's that's like what
winning looks like
um he's like you know i always loved
cars he goes cars are a where am i at in
life purchase because i can just look at
a look at a car that i owned and it
would tell me a story about where i was
in life you know like you know when i'm
graduating from when i'm graduating
right i'm coming of age or when i like
you know when i moved or when i got got
my first good job or like whatever he's
like a car basically marked you know
each chapter he's like that's how it is
for most people i kind of had that
insight which is like a car is like your
avatar that you use when you go around
the world a car says something about you
and uh yeah when you when you go upgrade
to the minivan it's because you're going
into family mode and like that's what i
kind of realized he goes people spend a
crazy amount of money on cars because in
the interview the guy's like how have
you been able to raise so much money he
goes
well i play in like the biggest market
he goes
15 of all people's gross income goes to
mobility half in buying their car and
half into fuel taxes repairs insurance
etc it's like so when you have this
thing that makes up fifteen percent of
what everybody makes
or just put differently like i think
it's like a third of your net worth you
know
if people are spending on you when they
buy a new car he's like the tam is just
enormous like you know it's like 5
billion
5 trillion a year
goes into cars or something insane like
that so he's like you know that's the
easy answer to how i've raised so much
money i went and played in this big
space and then i tried to reinvent it at
every every time i would do one i would
try to reinvent it so he's like you know
we were the first ones to be like we
would put the upfront price of a car on
the internet nobody was doing that at
their in the early days i think that's
the car's direct is he successful you
said that he got marching called does
that mean he was broke
uh doesn't necessarily mean he was broke
it means he didn't have enough
collateral for like what he borrowed for
his stock now if the stock recovered
which i don't know i haven't looked at
true cars
they're marketing
230.
million
yeah
that's that's yeah that does not look
like it has done very well since then so
uh
yeah it's like
basically
you know a third of where it was back in
2014 so yeah that's that's not doing so
well um and he says that in his things
like he's like i made a bunch and i've
lost it all many times over um and so
you know i'm sure this guy's done well
like i don't think he can build multiple
companies that get value to billions of
dollars take a company public i don't
think he can do that and like you got a
real you got to be like kind of really
[__] reckless to walk away with less
than you know 20 million at the end of
all that
dude i love people who too but anyways
swings even if they miss
like consistently or like you know in
this guy's case like he didn't entirely
miss he did actually build some amazing
things but like maybe he was just shy of
what it could have been another guy
who's doing that right now tell me what
you think about him adam newman the
founder of wework he just raised
250 million dollars in seed funding for
a one billion dollar
apartment
business i don't exactly know what the
business does but it sounds like it's we
live the thing that we talked about
where you you know it's like fancy
apartment buildings that are almost the
same you pay a premium because it's all
pre-designed and looks really nice and
it has a community on it which honestly
i think is awesome i also think wework
is awesome
what do you think about a guy like adam
newman taking another swing
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
i think it's great i think it's so easy
for people to [__] on him
uh and you people [__] on him for two
reasons one is
well i'll forget the reasons i'll give
the explanation the reason is just
simply like you know it's fun to hate on
somebody you know that you don't know
that like why and he's falling
they
they got too big-headed and then they
they crash people like that but
i think the criticism is what the
criticism is
wework failed well wework didn't really
fail it just didn't achieve the like
you know what we work work today we work
is still like you know uh like five or
six billion company more valuable that
than anything that we've ever built you
know so it's like uh yeah wework is
valued at 3.96 billion right now
publicly traded um
you know so it's not like it's not like
we work actually failed it's just
you know he raised too much money too
high evaluation didn't live up to that
uh that dream at that that promise and a
bunch of people got burned if you bought
the stock or you joined the company at
that really high price yeah you're
underwater for that so that's the first
criticism the second is
he lied cheated steal you know he
licensed the br he was like paying
himself out of the company for the
trademark of we
he like you know did stupid things like
you know this like summer camp where
everybody got drunk and whatever
those things to me are
somewhere between
a little whack a little messed up to
actually like understandable and more
common than you think when it comes to
these like hyper growth companies like i
don't think he's a liar really hardcore
kind of ego driven people
but there's crazy good there's crazy bad
is he crazy
in some cases it was bad but i think
that when i at least when i read about
him and i don't know the guy i've hung
out with um miguel the co-founder and my
my read on these guys is
i don't think you're lying i just think
that you got some things wrong and i
think that you're just like incredibly
enthusiastic and i don't know like is it
when you paint the picture of the future
and you end up being way wrong you're
not a liar you're just wrong
you know you're optimistic
but you still called it wrong but you're
not a liar or at least you don't you're
not a liar if you believe that
delusional is different right right
delusional or irrational is very
different than like lying or fraud and i
think
there's a line who knows if he crossed
it i don't know all the details i'm not
involved in all that but from from the
outside it looks to me like he was one
of these guys who is
a huge dreamer
irrational self-confidence so
unbelievable self-confidence that they
are going to pull it off that they're
going to pull off this crazy crazy dream
i do think they get you know high on
their own supply where they start to
think that like you know the stuff that
got them
to the to the point where you know
you're on the cover of time magazine and
everybody's throwing money at you to
fund you
then all of a sudden you think you know
i can't be touched and i've seen this
play out many many times i've gotten
burned on some of these so i've you know
that like i uh you know i invested in
tara and tara which was like you know um
the luna like crypto coin right and the
the founder of that was the same way
this guy doe quan super smart
charismatic
uh unbelievable confidence that his
thing was going to work and some some
people all along the way were saying
he's crazy
and then slowly but surely a bunch of
smart people gave him money you know
because it was like this guy's crazy but
he's kind of pulling it off and maybe he
is just crazy enough to pull it off and
we have many examples in history of
people who are crazy enough to pull it
off let's see if this happens
and um and then over time his ego
ballooned and it ballooned and it
ballooned and he kept basically taking
larger risks and tempting people to uh
to you know sort of call him on his
bluffing and
and then somebody did and the market
like a series of events happened and it
crashed and all went to zero and
everybody looks dumb and you know i lost
a million dollars of like you know what
i had and worth of luna
in like two days because
i believed that this guy was gonna be
one of the crazy ones to pull it off i
didn't think he was not crazy i thought
he was crazy and like might be the good
crazy and uh was worth the bet and so
on and other times i've bailed because i
thought you know what
i'm not falling for this sort of the
hero entrepreneur the charisma the the
visionary entrepreneur thing i owned
tesla stock
when it was uh really really low i
remember
um i remember at the time tesla was
valued at maybe like 2 billion
and 2 3 billion something like that and
i remember investing in it my dad was
like tesla they don't make any money
and i was like yeah but i think that
like you know here's my reason why i
think they're going to be big but abc
and then i said he's like yeah but like
you know it's already valued at 3
billion i was like well you know at the
time i think gm was like 25 billion or
something like that
um one of the big companies what's tesla
now like 500 billion
yeah i mean it hit a trillion so like
you know i would have rode 2 billion to
a trillion i can't do that basically
it was the first stock that i bought i
think i put in like 25k or something
crazy like that but 25k would have been
numbers
millions right
yeah at one point i calculated it was a
five million dollar
i would have had five million dollars i
what i did was i turned the 25k into
like 125k and i sold because i started
to get suspicious that like
damn this guy really over promises like
and he he does over promise he
overpromises on like when something will
be built how good it'll be like
he's pretty much wrong on the timing
always like he's he's been saying that
the cyber truck is coming out he's been
saying that the uh you know the model 3
would be more affordable than it is
he'll say that autopilot like he's been
charging people for autopilot like the
self-driving full you you buy fsd full
self-driving and it's like not full
self-driving and you've been paying
thousands of dollars for like multiple
years now and he always says it's right
around the corner right so like this guy
does have this i remember when i was
reading the the twitter stuff about like
people who are basically saying this
guy's a fraud tesla's a scam
um
it was very very convincing there was a
lot of convincing evidence i remember
like they went through 20 cfos
20 cfos in like a four-year time span
and like the new cfo was like some guy
who's never been a cfo before and like
somebody really smart once told me like
just follow the cfos the cfos know
what's going on with the company they
know the company health better than
anybody and like that made a lot of
sense to me i actually still believe
that principle it just turned out yeah
but
no no it was right which is that it was
on the brink of collapse consistently
and uh he kept pushing he threaded the
needle he pulled it off yeah
he pulled it off he threaded the needle
he pulled it off and there's still a bun
a mountain of evidence as to like that
it was very close to failing that
um he basically over promised slash that
over promise would be the generous term
you know sort of lied manipulated you
know to keep the stock up uh to prevent
it from getting like you know basically
uh crashing and and going out of
business there's a bunch of evidence
that supports that but the bottom line
is he pulled it off and i was you know
five million dollars wrong for selling
early
and um and so i've been on both sides of
this and i i think where i netted out is
some people literally are just con
artists and they are literally just
going to scab you and their charisma
will um will manipulate you and dupe you
into into believing in them
but they're
some of the best entrepreneurs do have
the same have such a similar profile
where they're irrational delusional
um willing to like run into a you know a
fire pit and they're like there's no way
you'll make it out and then you know
nine out of ten don't but the one out of
ten who do you know like change the game
and so i've just sort of landed on you
know what
i'm gonna
lean towards i'm gonna lean towards
optimistic on this because even though i
would be right
if i was pessimistic about it nine times
out of ten i'd missed the i'd have a
false negative on the one that actually
works out and that one will a pay for
all the losers in investing terms and b
like you know it's just more fun to sort
of like follow these entrepreneurs and
and understand what they're doing you
know and why they believe they can do
this and uh be more optimistic than a
hater towards them that's kind of where
i landed that's a good one
all right let me just tell you i'm gonna
i want to end with two things one is the
lamest thing i've seen on the internet
the past few weeks and number two is a
company that is making way more money
than i thought and i'm absolutely gonna
clone it eventually i'm gonna start with
the second one
go to perfect
yeah go to bitpipe.
so b-i-t-p-i-p-e
dot com tell me what you see
okay
oh my god all right i see a craigslist
looking website it says pit pipe is the
enterprise it professionals guide to it
resources browse this free online
library with the latest technical white
papers webcast product information all
right i don't know what this is but
basically so it's just a set of blogs
maybe
so content about click one of them
click one of them click content
management
okay
done
then click view now okay it looks like
it's a set of reports
so click view now so i did it for you
and says this is an article from
computer weekly it was released on
august 22 uh august 2022 and it's called
uh
like it's so technical i don't even know
what it actually is
what's the one that you're looking at
i'm looking at euro tunnel's digital
journey for realities of post-covet
travel and it tells me i could download
this e-zein ezine what the hell is it
all right and i'm gonna let me tell you
an even worse one this one's called how
to choose an hr software is that like
what people call a
a magazine on the internet uh easy yeah
is that what it's called it's it's old
so this one's there's one called how to
choose
listen to this one it's called how to
choose an hr software system an hr
system is one of the most important
purchases an organization makes nowadays
the stakes couldn't be higher
and download this key this guy this
e-guide and learn all the key steps in
setting up an effective buying process
and how to identify hr software features
then it says give us your corporate
email address your first name last name
company name job title seniority job
function number of employees industry
address country state zip phone
and just click download now and we'll
send it to you all right so this website
it's owned by a company
that
owns like 20 or 30 of these websites and
it only has about 3 000 customers
but it makes around 400 to 500 million
dollars a year in revenue
and the way it works yes sam no
no
no i refuse to accept this reality no
no way
cut this out
i don't like this i don't like this
it's public it's a publicly traded
company it's a publicly traded company
with a market cap of about two and a
half or three billion dollars
so it's owned by a company called this
exact thing bit pipe makes that much or
the whole company makes that much
the whole company which is roughly like
10 or 20 of websites like this
tech target so every company on this bit
by website you see how it says this is
from computerweekly.com
or this article is from networking
uh it's like flow route
socialnetworking.com this was from um
like this other website that talks about
global knowledge which is your guide on
information systems so they own like 10
or 20 publications that talk all about
like buying software for huge companies
and they get very few people coming to
these websites a month very few
but because the article is called how to
buy an hr system for a thousand plus
employees
there's around 2500 companies in america
that will pay them money to uh do a
couple things the first thing is they
want to contact the people the lady who
is giving in our her email and
information on an article on how to pick
an hr system is a lady who maybe 30
different hr customers will say hey i'll
give you 500 bucks if you can give me
that ladies information so i can call
her the second thing that they do is
they they'll track that lady that lady
linda she's gonna go to
computerweekly.com and look at an hr
software thing then she's gonna go to
information system and look at a cloud
uh
software thing and then uh what tech
target is gonna do is they're gonna go
to their clients and be like hey
hey [__] you there i got a lady
who's about to buy this thing that thing
and that thing you want to talk to her
you want holler and that's what they do
and that's how they make their money and
they make hundreds of millions of
dollars a year that's all they do they
go hey this motherfucker's about to buy
some cloud software
[Laughter]
they own a website actually called what
is and it's just like people googling
like like that but that'd be their
phrase like hey what it is bro yeah
yeah i got this chief information
officer at garner
yeah
yeah they want to score man
yeah she's texting me here
yeah yeah you up this is insane
sorry so but why do people
why
is that person who's ahead of hr why are
they landing at this website that looks
like it's from like 1979 why are they
this looks like you know back when the
internet was called the intranet and it
was like six computers this looks like
an intranet website it's not even an
internet site
because what the [__] are they gonna do
versus just googling because dude if you
google like what is a good software if
i'm if i'm uh you know like so if i'm
the the chief information officer of a
ten thousand or five thousand person
companies i'm gonna get my information
from a few different ways i'm gonna
watch loads of very specific webinars
that are on like a trade show a trade
magazine i'm going to read trade
magazine and by trade magazine i'm going
to learn about them because they're
hosting like a hundred person trade show
that's all talks about like how to pick
an hr software in vegas and it's really
just a really fun way for me to go and
watch the chippendales like get do their
thing but then i'm gonna go to like a
vendor that day and like you know we're
gonna hang out and do some blow
but then that so they're gonna go to
that website and learn all about it
because that's how they know them and
then occasionally that company's gonna
do a webinar in order to access the
webinar i'm gonna give them a bunch of
information and they're gonna sell that
information to the eight companies that
could possibly service me and that's how
the tech target makes money and so this
lady linda she's gonna go to all these
websites and meet all these people
because such a small it's a small small
industry there's like maybe tens or at
most hundreds of thousands of people who
do this and this is what i've been
thinking about this b2b media world it
is
awful say it with me it is awful it is a
horrible horrible industry it is awful
yes with a with a barrier or a uh
uh the
it's such a low bench line or been a
threshold of what's good and what's not
good the content is horrible and people
love it and these businesses work why
aren't we starting a company that just
beats these guys why aren't we starting
the most boring b2b media company but
we put our spin on it
just like mug shouty's did mugshots we
are to do to the b2b media industry
[__] that's what we're going to call
it the b2b [__]
[__] what's up yeah
it's going to be like a
like a radio show where it's gonna be
like
hey it's the b2b [__] today we're
gonna talk about information systems
you know like
yeah exactly we're gonna have a podcast
that's a radio station actually we're
just gonna have an am radio station
yeah we're gonna have a uh
you know we're gonna give pagers to
every cio in america and there's gonna
be a little soundcloud step it's gonna
be like b2b [__] in the morning
yeah this is gonna work exactly
yeah you know my favorite thing by the
way those radio stations that do the
cheaters segment you see this but they
like basically call
it's like hey will you call my boyfriend
and just see if he would cheat on me
and like they just like call the
boyfriend and then she's on the other
line and they basically trick him into
being like
yeah all right i'll meet you at home
depot what time and then they're like
actually rebecca's on the other line and
rebecca's like you son of a [__]
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
get one vendor your existing hr solution
on the line and then we're gonna call
being like hey are you interested in a
new hr solution and when they say yes
we're gonna be like oh we got work day
on the line work day what's up he's
gonna cheat on his shirt
and it's called churnbusters and we just
catch him in the act
no one has ever laughed at this style of
content except until or up until right
now we are the first people to ever make
tech targets
yeah but dude this is interesting right
the this business model is crazy
fascinating to me they make money
through webinars they make money through
like these e-papers or they [__] call
them a zine i mean that's just like
who's working here um so my next
business i already have started a
company it's like this community thing
i'm going to add this this style of
company i'm going to add it to uh this
is going to be in our portfolio of
products now let me show you the last
thing dude
last week
can i just say before you do that can i
just before you do that
this is this is yet again
a number seven we got a number seven a
sampar special
this is a sampard special it's like no
one's even heard of this website somehow
it does hundreds of millions of years a
year it looks like it's from 1982 and
like
you know
how do you even know these i don't know
but this is a samsbar special this is
why i like to talk to you because you
bring these things nobody nobody i know
in my entire life
i could i get hit every single person
i'd say hey you ever heard of bit pipe i
would get the answer no across the board
you're the only person
that i know that knows about this stuff
well
look up tech target market cap what is
it is it like two point
it's like multi-billion it's like one of
these companies that's like in plain
sight but no one pays attention to yeah
um so it's there
let's see the current price
so it's trading at seventy two dollars a
share with a market cap of two point one
billion dollars and like what was its
peak its peak was probably five or six
or seven
i mean it's not like a little thing uh
yeah
double yeah basically double where it's
at now
all right last thing
the lamest thing that i saw
last week so this guy posted on linkedin
a picture of him crying
and
it he's
the post starts off this will be the
most vulnerable thing i'll ever share
i've gone back and forth whether to post
this or not but we just had to lay off a
few of our employees and he talks about
how it's his fault and how he made all
these decisions and
i'm gonna have to file this under
things that i'm gonna take to the
[__] grave
i cannot believe this post
i cannot believe this post what happened
to like a man being stoic and just like
you know like just taking this just take
these feelings and just push them down
you know what i mean just accept it and
push them down
hey it's crazy on that shelf that just
has daddy issues make room yeah we got
something new i need to put on the shelf
that i'm burying deep down in my gut
yeah yeah yeah i want that problem to
walk over be like excuse me mind if i
scooch in right here that's what needs
to happen with this i cannot believe
this person shared this
is that ridiculous
i mean
i don't even understand it by the way uh
he goes
he goes uh i've seen a lot of i've seen
a lot of layoffs over the last few weeks
on linkedin most of these are due to the
economy or whatever other reason ours
my fault i made a decision in february
that i stuck with for too long
now i know my team will say we made this
decision together by the way they won't
they'll say you made this decision
they're not going to be like we all made
this mistake boss
um yeah so then he basically writes this
long thing and he writes it like in the
marketer style where it's every other
line like single line enter
one line enter and then he posts this
picture of himself looking into the
camera crying
and this has um
i think it has 50 000 likes and 10 000
comments but most of the comments are
just [__] on him which is hilarious
oh sorry you said what has 50 thousands
it has 50 000 likes 10 000 comments and
most of them are just making fun of this
guy so as as is deserved to be honest
like you know
at my first million we don't condone
bullying
but we definitely don't condone
absolutely faking the funk like this
guy's doing the the top comment that i
liked was some guy was like hang on did
you turn your ring light on before you
took this selfie because i can kind of
see the reflection uh it looks like you
turned a ring light on to take the
selfie of you crying to post on linkedin
and uh that's like that just calls it
out so perfectly the the the
inauthenticity of the fake authenticity
that this guy tried to try to portray i
condone some type of bowling i could
dome bowling this guy because if the
bullies had they done their job
nerds like this wouldn't be going around
existing this is the most ridiculous
thing i've ever seen i saw this and i
was like
bullies you failed us how on earth did
this guy get away with this is the
you need like you know in every
ecosystem it's like yeah well these the
plankton have to be there because
they're absorbing this and like you know
these parasites actually you need them
because of this
that's why we need bullies otherwise
yeah like this is gonna run rampant if
there's no bullying
yes this guy someone need he needed a
big brother he needed a big sister
someone to be like look this isn't how
you act this is not this isn't the right
way to behave when something like this
happens you dork i cannot believe
we're pro bully here at the my first
million podcast
dude there's just going to be a
generations of cool uh uh a generation
missing cool kids because of this
um no i saw this postman and i thought
this is the definition this is the
definition of small boy stuff
like when we say the definition of this
is what we're talking about
yeah this is this is this is small boy
stuff this is this is a small boy as it
gets i saw this and i was like oh man
i've seen i've seen a bunch of these
like like henry ward from um carter
wrote this letter of saying how he
screwed up and i was like okay that's
cool whatever this is the worst
example
i've ever seen of this i i think that
what do you think's gonna happen to this
guy's career like if you're a customer
of his i'd be like oh we like your code
must suck like you know like if you're
if your product is even 50 as weak as
you it's not gonna work
do you know what i mean
you know what i mean
dude some of these comments are
hilarious they're like um brandon braden
i understand these things happen happens
for a reason focus on the positive
let it go rest easy my sweet child rest
easy life starts off with a serious
comment it's like
asleep sweetly my sweet child
ever on linkedin this is the best
content on linkedin like the comments
the combination of the post and the
comments
almost on linkedin was the most
entertaining uh you know like social
media of the day from there from this
one post dude i was gagging reading it
man it was this was crazy i i felt
embarrassed for i just felt so
embarrassed for him you know how like um
we talk about cringe stuff i
legitimately cringed i remember my face
being like
like i just had that my face was
changing shapes reading this
yeah like i have this tooth that's like
a little sensitive and it just started
like ringing
[Laughter]
ah
like i ate too cold of ice cream like
that's how it felt when i read this it
was just like this uncomfortable this
uncomfortable feeling that i just needed
to pass
all right so that's the episode uh go
tell your friends tell your mom
you know go at us on linkedin go do what
you got to do it's my first
[Music]
you